some small businesses in the valley are
preparing for the holiday season
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us how they're managing the
pandemic
and the differences with orders this
year
the pandemic forced a lot of small
businesses to adjust their operations
and
some notice a difference when it comes
to the type of orders at the moment
sliding into the holidays we are
changing our approach to things felicia
parker and her family prepare
gift baskets fulfilling orders coming
into any occasion baskets
a las vegas business operating in the
loft space of parker's mountain's edge
home
i've been so thankful and grateful to be
a home-based business during this time
the setup helps cut overhead costs
it also allows parker to continue
managing orders and
adapting to clients needs now
[Music]
basket orders for the large holiday
baskets for the company events are no
longer being ordered it's the smaller
individual baskets for the individual
employee or customer
a similar scenario for popped a gourmet
popcorn business in henderson
we're pushing more towards the
individual
package the new trend as clients avoid
communal items
thank you the co-owner jean-francois
tells me the holidays remain crucial
it's about 30 percent of our business
throughout the year so we
really look forward for a good holiday
season and hopefully that's gonna you
know put us back on track
on track after a slip in sales because
of casinos temporarily closing and
canceled conventions but francois and
parker
expect business to pick up things are
coming back we're finally starting to
get some corporate orders
both owners say clients seem to prefer
shipping and delivery options to keep
everything contactless
back to you